a new study shows that puberty blockers
might cause depression so if you pump
little kids full of drugs to stop them
from going through puberty this might
kind of mess them up a little bit
breaking news I know stop the presses
this is a study that was done on animals
and it it found out that these puberty
blockers might have all these problems
all all decades after doctors began to
give these puberty blockers to Children
this study was the first of its kind
he's an animal model to examine the
potential neurological and psychiatric
effects of the puberty blockers and they
found that they had profound effects of
increased depression in female mice and
then a male mice increased stress and a
loss of interest in female mice profound
profound effects all 22 years after a
doctors quacks started prescribing these
to kids